we have a very interesting new
development in the
for now hypothetical 2024 republican
presidential match-up
ron desantis and donald trump are
essentially even right now in terms of
the betting odds for 2024. now i want to
remind everybody
this this is not polling okay this is
you go to predicted.org and you can bet
on who you believe will be the nominee
for the last many many months donald
trump has been the clear but
increasingly by a smaller margin
favorite in terms of the betting odds to
be the 2024 republican nominee over the
last two days after the fbi served a
search warrant at trump's home
ron desantis actually pulled ahead and
then as of moments ago in a virtual tie
donald trump and ron desantis for 2024
in terms of not who will you vote for
but who will you bet on being the
nominee
uh right now in order to win a dollar
you have to bet 37 cents on donald trump
being the nominee and in order to win a
dollar you have to bet 36 cents on
desantis being the nominee it is a
virtual tie
and every reason to believe that this
change
is tied to the search warrant and the
increasing legal problems for trump
trump pleading the fifth more than 400
times yesterday which i will talk about
in the next segment
in terms of polling how does the polling
actually look it still favors trump very
clearly new polls we have a a yahoo news
poll
yahoo news poll from late july early
august that has trump plus nine
and then before that um
at the end of july a harris harvard poll
that has trump plus like 30 okay so it
is tightening
but also donald trump is still clearly
the favorite among current republican
voters we are going to be watching these
numbers very closely i don't want to
spend a lot of time on it today but we
are certainly going to be keeping an eye
on it the numbers are tightening and
remember that desantis hasn't announced
anything trump hasn't either but trump
has been all but announcing saying
things like we might have to do it again
i think you're going to be very happy
with what we decide etc etc it is not
clear that trump would necessarily win
a contested republican primary which
would be an extraordinary thing for a
one-term president who lost
an unprecedented situation could be
facing us in 2024
but we have 2022 coming up first and so
that's where our focus will be let me
know your thoughts on where you see this
republican primary going find me on
twitter deepakman we will talk about
pleading the fifth after this short
break